what's going on guys today we're going
to be explaining every american quirk
disappeared in my here academia despite
this series rarely ever leaving japan
the us has still been referred to as the
home of heroes by hirokoshi himself in
volume 14 and by all for one in one of
the more recent chapters the reason for
this is that america was the first
country to introduce an official hero
licensing system which obviously is a
system that every other country adopted
over the following decades
last year i made a video breaking down
the full history surrounding that if
you're interested but for this video
today we're going to focus on the quirks
instead of everything else before we get
into it though don't forget to smash
that sub button if you're new to the
channel and drop a like if you want to
see future content like this
also i want to thank searchrot for
sponsoring this video which in my
personal experience is the best vpn for
protecting yourself online if you're
someone like me who occasionally uses
public wi-fi or stumbles across websites
that might not be so secure surfshot
will keep your data safe by encrypting
everything said between your devices in
the internet for just one subscription
you can stay protected on unlimited
devices including phones tablets
computers and even consoles and this is
one of the many reasons why experts rate
cell shark as the best vpn for security
another great benefit is that by
connecting to one of their 3 000 servers
worldwide you can change your ip address
and access content not usually available
in your country for me this meant
connecting to netflix us to watch death
note and connecting to netflix australia
to watch the finale of rick and morty
the day came out but of course the
possibilities are endless if any of this
interests you then right now you can go
to search deals turtle to get 83 of a
two-year plan which works out to just
two dollars and 21 cents a month on top
of that there's a 30-day full money-back
guarantee so even if you're not quite
sure just click the link in the
description and use called total quirk
to try out the service for 30 days to
see if it's for you
okay so the first power on this list
belongs to star and stripe who was
introduced as the number one american
hero and unlike midoriya this is someone
who looks like they could actually be
all my secret love child
in chapter 330 the name of her quirk was
revealed to be new order and it gives
her the potential to rewrite reality by
touching something and then calling out
its name once the correct name has been
said star can make up a rule of her
choice that the target has to follow
with an example being how she touched
the air itself and made a rule that the
atmosphere would disappear 100 meters
ahead by saying those words her quirk
caused the air to instantly vanish in
the area she specified creating a vacuum
where shiguraki wasn't able to breathe
another instance of new order is how she
stopped this deadly laser beam by saying
the words this laser is holdable and you
can see how the laser then started to
unnaturally curve into a ball of energy
rather than blasting into her like it
normally would have done
considering those examples i think it's
fair to say this quirk is the closest
thing to genuine magical powers you've
seen in the series since it's as if you
know star is casting a spell on her
target that makes impossible things
happen
her ability also works on living things
as well proven by the fact that she has
a rule in herself that constantly gives
her super strength and although that
strength isn't on almight's level it's
enough for her to go toe-to-toe with
super super archie which by default
makes her one of the strongest people on
the planet
she stated in the manga that this rule
about strength is always active implying
that there isn't a time limit for how
long the effect of new order will last
but instead it's down to her to decide
when the rules turn off
that brings us to the biggest downside
of star's power which is that she can
only make new rules for two things at a
time meaning if she wants to create a
third rule she first has to turn off one
of the existing rules that are already
in place
we saw this weakness demonstrated during
a fight with sugaraki because in order
to make the laser holdable while having
super strength at the same time the
other rules she made about the air had
to be turned off
a different drawback is that the power
only works on people when she knows
their true like full legal name i guess
and if we use a quick example i guess
darby you know we didn't know his full
name for the first five seasons of my
academia so if she had ever encountered
him during that time she wouldn't have
been able to use new order directly
against him
overall new order is easily one of the
most elaborate abilities harikoshi she's
come up with and i feel like he was
heavily inspired by jujitsu kaizen when
he made this since the nature of it
seems a lot like a cursed technique
given that he's friends with the author
of jiu-jitsu kaizen in real life i guess
it's theoretically possible that they
might have you know come up with this
idea together or spoken about it i mean
obviously we don't know that but it
would be pretty cool if that turned out
to be the case
one interesting thing about star and
stripe is that her origin can be traced
back to the two heroes movie when her
entire family was saved by young almight
while he was doing hero stuff in
california this was the moment that
solidified him as her role model and
it's why she tried to emulate him in
both her design and personality however
compared to all might she's way more
casual when it comes to people around
her being killed
anyway the fact this scene in two heroes
is now confirmed to be canon it got me
wondering what kind of overpowered quote
do you think her sister has because
being siblings you'd imagine it would at
least be similar to star herself
next up on this list we have christopher
scarline aka captain celebrity who was
the former top hero in the us before his
license got revoked due to a number of
different lawsuits while he did
eventually get the license back many
many many months later it was never
stated where he ended up on the rankings
after this but obviously you know he
lost his number one position
just like starring stripe his quirk has
a lot of layers to it so i guess the
first thing to mention is that he has an
invisible barrier covering his body at
all times that protects him from
physical attacks and extreme
temperatures the barrier has been shown
to be incredibly sturdy on a few
different occasions like the time he
withstood multiple explosions directly
to his body while holding up the tokyo
sky egg with his bare hands
by touching other people the barrier can
also be extended to them but the
drawback is that the more people captain
celebrity decides to protect the less
effective the barry is at protecting him
additionally during chapter 53 of
vigilantes he showed that it's possible
to transfer 100 of the barrier to
another person if he wants to as long as
he maintains physical contact
besides that his flight quirk gives him
the ability to fly around at
ridiculously fast speeds which is a
totally separate thing from the barrier
as he specified that the barrier around
his body is not what propels him to fly
in addition to flights he has super
strength that's probably equal if not
greater than star stripes with his feats
including the incident i mentioned
earlier when he held up the sky egg as
well as another time when he lifted up
an entire cruise ship out of the water
understandably the other aspects of his
quirk helped him to do these things but
you have to admit that it would still be
impossible without an insane level of
physical strength that surpasses
virtually everyone else in this universe
if you want to know more about captain
celebrity's backstory then the link is
in the description for another video i
made explaining that but for now let's
move over to pony tsunatori from class
1b
according to her character page she's a
japanese-american student that came over
from the us which explains why motima
was able to trick her into saying things
in japanese because our understanding of
the language isn't as advanced as the
natural-born students ponies quirk is an
interesting one called horn cannon and
as the name implies it allows her to
shoot out horns from her head that then
immediately grow back and you know when
you look at it like that it's not too
dissimilar from monitor's pop-up quirk
although obviously there are still some
fundamental differences but i guess the
idea of something just coming out of
your head and then growing back straight
away that much they have in common
because of this she can send out a
flurry of horns to overwhelm her
opponents but the real advantage of this
power comes from her telekinesis
using her mind pony can control up to
four horns simultaneously enabling them
to move through the air however she
wants with an example being how she
glides through space using two horns
like a hoverboard they can take her
super high into the sky which
effectively gives her the power of
flight if she uses it correctly and also
it means the horns are a method of
transportation as well as being weapons
we saw in the joint training arc how
ponies horns can manipulate people's
movements by hooking on to them with the
drawback being that she starts feeling
weighed down the more separate people
she carries on the flip side when all
four horns are used in unison instead of
being separated they can move with a lot
more power as shown when audrey got
sound into the jail cell which was way
quicker than when she was using one horn
per person
in terms of other weaknesses it should
be said that the horns can be destroyed
quite easily when up against a person
who has a decent amount of brute
strength but that doesn't stop them from
being super painful if they manage to
stab into someone
like most of class 1b we didn't probably
get to see her quirk in action till
season 5 came around however she still
lived up to her first name in the sports
festival by galloping on all fours in
the background of the cavalry battle to
me this type of movement raised a lot of
similarities to cow lady who is the next
american hero on this list
while we have absolutely no idea where
she places on the hero charts what we do
know is that she has a transformation
quirk that massively increases her
strength and durability and turns her
into a cow that wears shades
when she's in this form she runs on all
fours and becomes so tough that she
brushed off a direct hit from a missile
and on top of that the horns on her head
are presumably good for ramming into
things
these horns actually remain in place
whether she's transformed or not but
regardless we didn't really get to see
that much of her quirk in action because
the villain team that she was fighting
against ran away pretty quickly these
two bad guys have only ever been
referred to as the la villains and back
in all my younger days they robbed a
casino in california and were trying to
make a run for it coincidentally both of
them happen to have transformation
quirks as well with the red one being
able to turn his arms into rocket
launchers and the other guy transforming
into a monster that looks like it
belongs in star wars
the rocket launcher villain could shoot
a maximum of one missile from each arm
at the exact same time and in his fight
with all might he proved on two separate
occasions that he could rapidly fire off
a third missile afterwards these rockets
packed a lot of power considering that
only one of them destroyed an entire row
of police cars but as i said cow lady
was able to shrug them off pretty easily
it was these two la villains that nearly
killed star stripes family when she was
a child as the blue villain was inches
away from landing on top of their car
and crushing them in the process but
luckily david shield and all might
happen to be passing through on their
way to a lecture
because david is from california his
quirk also has a place on this video
even though it's objectively one of the
worst i've ever seen in the team up
mission side manga his power was
revealed to be squirmy fingers which
from the looks of it lets him bend his
fingers as far back as they can go and
that's it
so honestly this is one of the few
quirks that i'm pretty sure is is you
know actually a thing somewhere in the
real world but in david's defense
squirmy fingers is quite useful for him
given how much he works with his hands
anyway as i'm sure most of you know if
you've watched the two heroes movie his
daughter melissa shield ended up being
quirkless and one thing we learned from
team admissions was that she would watch
videos of heroes on youtube during her
childhood in particular there was this
guy who was ranked 35th on the american
hero charts at the time but sadly it
wasn't said what his power actually was
although judging from this image i
imagine it's something to do with
strength as most of the american heroes
seem to have something to do with that
and also his headband here reminded me a
little bit of magneto so you know who
knows maybe there's a little bit of a
magnetism plus strength combined or
something like that i wouldn't be
surprised because these american heroes
all seem to have layers to their quirks
more than just one simple thing
putting that aside in the background of
this chapter we saw a few more quotes
that melissa observed in her childhood
including this tree of characters that
had stretchy arms triangle ears and a
shark head and her child friend who
could breathe fire i'm not trying to
start a conspiracy theory here but one
other character we know who could
breathe fire is deku's dad who's
mysteriously been working abroad for all
these years so all i'm saying is there's
a non-zero percent chance that this is
midoriya's half-brother
finally the last quirk from the us that
we've seen is from electo plant who can
generate and shoot out electricity but i
already spoke about this character a
couple weeks ago for my video about the
best anime original quirks so check that
one out if you want to see my thoughts
on who i think should be his new intern
with that said thank you for watching
this video on every quest from the usa
so far and i'm pretty confident that a
year from now there'll be at least a
couple more that we can add to this list
till then don't forget to smash that sub
button and until the next one peace out